something going toward the rim
and it comes to Durant he's going to try
to win it
Kevin Durant hits a three-pointer and
the sonics win the ball game
hold everything it is going to be
reviewable and see if Come On Son yes
sir he doesn't have to put on the weight
that you're looking for but he does have
to get the strength and
but the strength is this is the strength
three pointers is a strength when you
he's got 35. Kobe loses it
Westbrook back to Durant
[Applause]
get a quality look finally blocked by
Kevin Durant
Westbrook back for Duran another
three-point lead for Oklahoma City
right now Oklahoma City on that 13-2 run
to folosha
we'll throw in
[Music]
here
an easy shot it's well behind the
three-point line but when you're 6-10
with long arms and you've got that
elevation Oklahoma City the Thunder 46
and 16. third best in the NBA
from San Antonio where they play
tomorrow night Kevin Durant with a sweet
move on Kg for two yeah that was
beautiful beautiful move
He's listed at six times but he's really
taller than that and plays even taller
yeah absolutely Mike yeah they say he's
6 10 6 11. no one will give you the
right count about what he is this Tom
Collison comes away with us
Fisher had a huge three-point basket
with 15 and a half seconds left and look
at Durant but not a challenge and runs
anything he wants anything
well here's the thing is he was on the
dance floor and he was dancing he left
his partners
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man he punched it on Gortat oh
brought it back from Main Street 6 of 16
here in the first quarter Durant showing
Randall every move he's got and
look how low he was on that play behind
the battle I don't know what that last
part was and then he double pumped oh
there was a lot of action on that plate
guarantee you
Durant
incredible opportunity grand for three
it's good Kevin Durant from downtown and
Golden State takes the lead all right
there Kevin Durant though so gifted
comes down and just pulls up
and knocks it in but at the other end
they had to get the two for one and then
they had to foul the moment it hit
Draymond Green's hand shot clock at five
[Applause]
Kevin Durant way outside delivers Kevin
Durant from downtown it's a six-point
game
that's the same spot in game three last
year
[Applause]
I mean my goodness
Kevin Durant
put the kids to sleep
Saturday night right I'll tell you what
he can score now a little easier he
knows how to play
the ranch hitting the fade away three
[Applause]
five seconds
Durant good night a three
dagger
then this time he's clearing everyone
out let me just go one on one
and what a job
of Barton and you see how once again he
is able to find his spot on the
three-point line Indiana's four or five
from long range Durant's got 11. Craig
goes down Durant has got a highlight
KD doing damage from the perimeter have
the foul to give ankle breaker oh
Kevin Durant is one bad bad man that was
cold Wayne Right with eight to shoot
back to KD with six Durant driving on
Hardaway pull-up jumper Durant got it
and Phoenix has a two-point lead 35 for
Durant create the space and in his size
I'm gonna shoot up over the top of
excellent